[Música]
domingo de carnaval y desde las seis de
la mañana ríos de Janeiro está en fiesta
estamos en el Boy tolo que es el bloco
comparsa más famoso de Río puede llegar
a tocar durante 24 horas Porque muchos
músicos se van turnando y aquí tenemos
el Ministerio del amor Hola hoy
día
nuestro disfrazo homenajea el Ministerio
del noviazgo nuestro presidente Lula
prometió que este año todo el mundo se
besaría en la boca y encontraría un
novio y se enamoraría
el amor volvió con Lula el amor volvió
[Música]
dos años en Carnaval Y ahora Estamos
matando todas las ganas que teníamos en
nuestro Carnaval callejero Río de
Janeiro tiene que tener eso la cultura
el carnaval libre y el pueblo en la
calle tienen que estar encima de todo
el carnaval de Río de Janeiro mueve unos
871 millones de dólares según datos del
ayuntamiento de Río de Janeiro los datos
son apabullantes más de 450 desfiles
autorizados y cerca de cinco millones de
personas estarán estos días
para celebrar la fiesta más querida por
los brasileños el carnaval
[Música]